iceland's voters have given almost
two-thirds of the seats to the
conservative parties who were in power
when the country's financial crisis hit
many were drawn to their promises of
mortgage relief and tax cuts party
leaders say Icelanders are fed up of the
austerity of the past four years people
knew that the hard times where I had in
2009 but they were hopeful and they were
introduced to a plan which would bring
us quicker out of the out of the crisis
done has been reality so people are now
looking forward and asking themselves I
mean what kind of a plan is the most
likely one to bring more growth more job
creation to close the budget deficit
voters turned away in droves from the
Social Democrats and their coalition
partners the greens supporters say they
did the best possible job under the
circumstances but most voters didn't
agree many icelanders also disagreed
with the government's efforts to join
the European Union the winning
conservatives oppose you membership they
say Iceland needs to tackle its own
problems first